so
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you guys enjoyed that montage as much
as i did then you're gonna love
the full mix all 2400 submissions
18 years of collective effort
packed into one three and a half hour
video
also coming later this week i'm gonna be
breaking down the art that i created to
kick off this challenge
in a very stylized bite size kind of
video you guys are gonna really enjoy it
now if you didn't get a chance to join
this community challenge
i have another cd community challenge
coming at the end
of this month so definitely subscribe so
you guys don't miss out on all the
awesome content coming down the line
here for the channel
and please leave a comment down below
what are your five
favorite renders leave some time codes
i'm curious to see what you guys think
i'm also going to announce my patreon
very soon it's going to be a way for me
to give you guys my cg assets
all of my custom packs and project files
i'll also be doing personal art reviews
releasing exclusive tutorials and behind
the scenes videos
and i want to give a huge thank you to
all
2400 artists who submitted to this
challenge
and worked hard over the last month to
the top 100 artists congrats for making
this awesome montage
and to the five winners you guys are
insane congratulations huge thank you to
quixel
wacom coco pny and aftershocks for
providing an
incredible pool of prizes if you guys
didn't win this challenge or make the
top 100 montage don't worry there's
gonna be a full montage coming this week
but really it's all about learning and
growing and i hope you guys did that
over the last
month and that's what this channel is
all about it's about learning and
growing together
in our passions every single week so i
appreciate you guys thank you for taking
the time to watch this awesome video
share it with your friends
share with some 3d artists and i'll see
you guys
very soon peace
[Music]
you